- I'm Poppy.
(loud poof)
Oh, hello.
What's your name?
- Um, Andrew Luce.
- You look like you
make electronic music.
- Well, yeah, I
happen to be a DJ.
(upbeat synthesizer music)
Whoa!
- Do they play your
music on the radio?
- Well, not yet.
- If you get on the radio,
you'll be a lot more famous.
- Okay, well, how do I do that?
- All you have to
do is keep doing
what people like
over and over again.
- Oh, that seems easy.
I know how to copy and paste.
- Electronic DJs copy and paste
better than anyone
else on the planet.
The only part of the song
that people care
about is the drop,
so make a drop over
and over again.
- Why didn't I think of that?
- Because I'm Poppy.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Hey, this is really easy.
Wow, I can't wait until I'm
more famous like you, Poppy.
- Being famous is really
fun, but everyone still dies.
- Wait, what?
- Forever.
You never get to come back,
even though everybody tells you
that you get to live
forever in Heaven.
- Can I leave now?
- Fame is important because
it validates our existence.
- Please, can I go home?
I really don't wanna
do this anymore.
- Everybody wants
to be remembered,
so some people dress up
as a cartoon character
in pursuit of likes
and followers.